andrew is in boston hey andrew welcome
to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me on sure what's
up
so um i'm 24 years old i'm engaged i'm
about to marry somebody with
220 000 in student debt
should doctor or lawyer
uh no she's she's going to be a doctor
of veterinary medicine
okay good okay all right yeah so i'm
saving up enough money and plan to have
enough cash by the time she's done with
school to be able to pay off that debt
in cash wow what are you doing yeah
i'm a chemical engineer okay what are
you making
i make about 135 a year wow and when do
you all get married
uh we are getting married in two months
and when does she graduate
she graduates three years from now so
just to give you a breakdown on the debt
she has 60 from undergrad
she's one year in so she has 40 from
that
and then each three years is
accumulating another 40. so
are you going to cash flow hers from
this point forward
that's that's my question i'm not sure
because
yeah i would do that i would do that
before i paid on the existing debt
yeah you got a good income and a good
plan and a good head on your shoulders
one thing about chemical engineering
they taught you math right
yeah now is she working while she's in
college as well no
she's not probably not is she no i mean
it's hard for veterinarians yeah
school eight to five it's like going to
med school yeah it's hardcore
yeah yeah man i i don't think you should
be saving
to pay off debt i think you should be
cash flowing cash flow is job one
any money above being able to cash flow
her way out that you can throw back at
the debt
is job too yes so what about
investing then would you not none let's
get her out of school and get this
cleared up before we do anything yeah
she's a good investment like we were
just talking about this is a good
investment she's going to make a great
income
assuming she chooses well on how to use
her dvm
there are dvms that make more than uh
medical doctors lots
of them because they chose how they were
going to operate their practice
in a in a way that was uh successful
with money
now some dvms get caught up in you know
going 200 000 in debt and then don't
make any money because they're not
careful on how they build their career